time for our scene and unseen segment we
unpack the big cultural stories of the
day and for that way during the Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo all right
Raymond I know you're excited because
the Johnny Depp he was granted a big win
and his defamation lawsuit against his
ex Amber Heard today
yeah well Laura the court awarded dip 15
million in total which could likely buy
about four black pearls as I argued from
the beginning and you'll remember this
Johnny Depp won this trial the moment
the judge alliled the cameras in because
it gave him the opportunity to tell his
side of the story and reclaim his
reputation and thereby work again in
truth the public was the real jury and
say what you want about the argument
Johnny Depp was a fascinating presence
on the stand and Amber Heard not so much
I was just sitting there on this on on
this carpet looking at the dirty carpet
wondering how I wound up on this carpet
and why I was never why I never noticed
that the carpet was so filthy before
he came to New York
two
fight for the relationship don't call me
a liar it's all I said just don't call
me a liar
you know in theater Laura they call that
squeezing the pity out of the
performance and look whether she was
telling the truth or Not The credibility
was what was at stake here and the jury
and the public didn't feel she had it
that she was faking
um but the big news here is the cultural
component which is Johnny Depp taking
domestic abuse of men out of the shadows
and into the center of the culture it's
the first time we've heard that and I
think we'll be seeing a lot more of
Johnny Depp in theaters soon
and what speaking of troubled couples
what what's going on the first lady Jill
oh yeah well first lady Jill Biden in a
new Harper's bizarre interview reveals
that she and the president have their
fights via text she calls it affecting
okay only like her husband
Communications can be a problem Laura
fexting in the Urban Dictionary means
texting while having intercourse oh why
why is she fighting him with him over
text though why oh well she she claims
she doesn't want the Secret Service to
hear them fighting but as Biden reminded
her everything they text ends up in the
National Archives so the people in the
hall can't hear you but all the
posterity will soon be able to read all
the nasty things you sent your husband
and the real issue here is when a man is
cognitively challenged he's got
pressures and stress Laura why are you
texting him nasty things and calling him
names that's probably not the best tact
at this moment well maybe she's just
upset because he doesn't call her Doctor
Jill like
the archives for that evidence all right
and the president had some some more
trouble today didn't he as he unveiled
the baby formula plan this is today's
Biden by the numbers
[Music]
track here
today we're announcing the United
Airlines has agreed to offer cargo space
for Kendall neutral care uh for the
delivery of 3.7 bottles of the formula
well Laura that's 3.7 more bottles than
they had before one of the United Pilots
probably needed to take a few sips to
sustain him as he carried the other
three bottles to those hungry children
so look this is progress we don't want
to limit it I think he meant 3.7 million
well the numbers can be very confusing
after all that fexting with Jill Raymond
I guess thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else